from your book writing for the green
light have there been success stories
where people have reached out to you
yeah
and it was very meaningful to see it
actually because you know it's I I got
okay writing for the green light is not
I wrote this great script in three days
and I'm emotionally invested in it and I
want to see it on a big screen writing
for the green light is about writers who
want to write professionally who want to
figure out that great question that no
other book really answers and it's
really just how do you begin that
process how do you talk to people how do
you pitch your work and so that's why we
kind of focus on the goldmine genres
that are like two tried and tested
they're going to be around forever type
things so the process of writing a
script or getting a job as a writer is
not I wrote the script and I'm going to
sell it writing begins with being able
to showcase you can write writing it
requires that when a production company
is in a crunch and they need a writer
who can just get the job done the first
time around you're the person to hire so
writing for the Green Line is about
helping writers become that if that's
what they want to become so the success
stories I saw were people change their
style of writing they gave it a you know
a shot and you know one woman wrote out
to me that she read the book she wrote a
woman in peril thriller she sent it off
and was basically given a writer for
hire agreement a step agreement which
was basically we really liked your work
you obviously know the kind of genre
that we like to work with
we need this script written can you
write it give us a treatment you know I
had another woman reach out to me
basically saying I read this book I
thought it was interesting so I gave it
a shot she wrote a Christmas dog family
movie and basically she did it as kind
of a wouldn't say a joke but like I'm
just going to spit this out and see what
happens
you know so she wrote it in two weeks
and all of a sudden this script got a
lot of a ten
she got an agent at one festivals and it
got optioned I don't think it's been
produced but I mean like that's the kind
of thing or it's just writing for the
green light is about those writers who
find that like there's some okay
everyone in Hollywood it feels like is a
screenwriter everyone has a script or
they dabble with it etc and the truth is
most of them are really really good
writers they just write the wrong stuff
and because they write the wrong stuff
they blend in with all those piles of
scripts in production houses that no one
takes seriously so it's about writing
stuff that's going to elevate you make
you stand out and have your work be
taken seriously to have it get noticed
that's sort of the idea of it so I've
had a couple of other people who've had
successes one guy got a was asked to
write a treatment I flesh out a full
treatment of the story and he got a
first draft out of it it's beginning
that process so it's only been 2 years
or so and you know it's getting real
results which I love it's it's
meaningful to see that there are people
out there who are fulfilling their goals
in a way that just never had it spelled
out as how you do it this is the a visit
the instruction manual for your game
plan you know you had a lot of positive
comments on Amazon and the video
interview that we did with you back was
it I think it was more 2014 for us but
wasn't 2014 March 2015 2015 okay sorry I
only remember that okay it was around I
knew where I was leaving or other
shifting to DRGs
okay all right well one comment that
came in on the video interview that we
did which I felt was constructive
question was one lady put regarding gold
mine genre that I don't understand
something if one should focus on gold
mines on resent how do deeper more
meaningful indie movies get picked up at
film festivals The Wrestler was Robert
Siegel's first screenplay
but the wrestler isn't a gold mine genre
movie it's a quote boring drama as you
would playfully describe it thank you to
anyone with an opinion on this
I felt it was a you know just construct
a question totally valid gosh yeah
obviously there are great dramatic films
I say don't write dramas I say don't
write comedies I say don't write a lot
of things not because they aren't
successful films it's its most
independent production companies or
distribution companies those require a
lot more work they're a lot more
difficult and complex to package
together ok it's I don't know the story
of the wrestlers as far as and how it
came from you know embryonic idea to how
it got to Darren Aronofsky but he's not
a nobody in town sure and if he was
connected to the writer in some way or
how it got from point A to point B I'm
not visible to that I know the other
story that always gets brought up as a
Diablo Cody so when she wrote Juno the
same situation it's a it's a indie
boring drama Scott describes how is that
possible well she wasn't a first-time
writer she's a first-time screenwriter
but she had a very successful blog she
had I believe a book that she had
written with a manager about her
experiences because her blog was all
about being a stripper and some of the
the trials and tribulations of that so
she got a lot of attention for having a
fan base as a blogger then wrote a book
and then you know basically had this
great idea for a movie but she also had
a network of a manager and agents and a
fan base of people that she kind of had
formulated who she was as a writer and
then had you know people connected in
Hollywood to be able to get that past
from point A to point B she's connected
she's not your newbie writer who has
zero connections in Hollywood so the
people who have zero connections in
Hollywood that route isn't the easiest
to get into so writing for the Green
Line is about getting to that point how
do you get to the point of having a you
know a collection of professionals to
speak to to pitch your ideas to that's
what it's really about and there's all
kinds of great genres in the indie space
but a lot of them are also developed
internally
where you know pre-sales are put
together or production company a has a
relationship with some major talent and
that major talent brings in a story
that's very interesting distribution
company brought on board and is how to
pre sale it to six companies and
different territories on the planet and
then they hire a writer or they go out
to agencies and they find a writer who
is up-and-coming that they can assign it
to like that's kind of how that stuff
works so to get there you kind of have
first have to pass the litmus test of
being seen as a writer that can deliver
and getting yourself kind of getting
your feet wet in the business you know
that's a major leap and you can get
there and I'm just saying don't go out
of the gate writing that stuff don't
have those great films and those great
scripts of yours be the ones you
showcase the Hollywood people because
people are just going to go this is
great but we've got thirty others just
like them and they're connected to other
projects that are attached to something
this one isn't so I'll put it to the
side and we'll see what happens and
usually nothing does and it doesn't mean
it's not a great script it just means
it's not attached to things so to
overcome that hurdle the gold mines
honors are this is a great stepping
stone to getting to that level where
when a production company or an agent or
whomever is looking for that person who
can make something happen
magical on the page you're the person
they call instead of thousands of other
scripts they have sitting on file
someplace that's the idea of right and I
know the Diablo Cody was referenced and
in one of your videos too and what about
like similar is like a Tucker max
somebody like that where he had a blog
same type of thing I don't know if he
was new to the industry but it sounds
like it's similar to that there was
already a following there and so it
wasn't just like a newbie at the gate
look the idea is like there has to be an
end user if you want people to transact
on what you're creating whether you're
writing a script whether you're selling
a product that you invented whatever it
is like if you want to transact on
whatever it is that you're inventing you
have to have people to put it in front
of in the blogging sphere today
especially with YouTube influencers and
all this and the reason YouTube
influencers are so popular at least on
my side of the business with a good cast
and movies and stuff is because they
have an actual numerical figure attached
to their names of the people that they
reach so if you have a film like you
know camp Takota is probably the most
known example you have YouTube
influencers who in some ways redesigned
how we communicate in pitch movies to
people and get people involved early and
all that but the truth is they're not
doing anything that hasn't been done
since the beginning of time in terms of
having finding an audience understanding
what that audience wants and then
speaking to them and catering to them
honestly you're doing the exact same
thing with film courage you have a core
group of people who you know view the
videos they have a vested interest in
learning more about this business and
how they can improve their career within
it and you know when is we just did with
the Alba Cody when you ask when they ask
questions about but how does this work
out of that work those are questions you
ask people like me and like other you
know people you've interviewed to get
the answers
you